it was first promised in December 2020
by the then culture secretary Oliver
Dowden a year later his replacement
Nadine Doris said the gambling white
paper was coming she was reshuffled and
it was delayed last April we were told
it was a matter of weeks but then Boris
Johnson's Premiership collapsed and it
was delayed again now after two and a
half years five delays three prime
ministers four culture secretaries six
gambling ministers finally the white
paper will be published tomorrow by the
latest culture secretary Lucy Fraser
in that time the gambling industry has
been busy pouring cash into politics and
Sky news's Westminster accounts tool
allows us to show you just how much
gambling gaming racing companies have
splashed out over 200 000 pounds on
donations to MPS this Parliament almost
all of that in the form of tickets to
Big sporting events and hospitality
the top Source lobbying firmed the
betting and gaming Council who gifted
over 90 grand in freebies to more than
40 MPS its CEO is Michael Duggar former
labor Minister who is well connected in
Westminster the MP who's made the most
is conservative Lawrence Robertson who
has had 33 and a half thousand pounds in
Hospitality on top of almost sixty
thousand pounds for being an advisor
it could be a lot more though as any
gift less than 300 pounds doesn't have
to be declared and Tori MP Scott Benton
who was secretly filmed by the Times
newspaper seemed to suggest the system
is open to abuse he said without saying
too much you'd be amazed at the number
of times I've been to the races and the
ticket comes to 295 pounds
tomorrow we'll find out whether all this
has paid off we expect a new mandatory
levy on industry profits and state
limits on slot machines and new rules to
slow down online casino games more
controversial measures though could go
to consultation and the government after
all this could still run out of time